born in a basement to the sand of
artillery above one day old maya is yet
to feel the warmth of the sun on her
face
i wish for a peaceful future for her
all the rest is just details
maya is a child of this war a victim of
it tucked away underground somewhere in
kharkiv
in her mother's arms away from the harm
of russian artillery
the worst memory of these days is
running pregnant to the cellar and
hiding from the plane the scariest
this hospital was hit
three out of the seven wards have been
damaged
and now they live in fear of another
attack
the reality is we can't even name this
hospital these expectant mothers are
hidden away behind a bomb proof door
they have their supplies
right here
and these are the conditions these women
are giving birth under
you
through the narrow corridor we find more
women
we'll call her karina which means strong
nobody expected this it was quiet in the
basement warm and cozy but it's mentally
difficult because i want to be back home
to be with my family to see a peaceful
sky
there's not much space to move
simple
dark and dull
the war takes its toll on mothers
while some have the warmth of their
mother's bodies others struggle
because of the stress of the war the
mother gave birth prematurely the child
has problems with her lungs and has to
have the support to receive oxygen and
has to be fed via tube
it's not only the newborns who struggle
we need ventilators we need a mobile
x-ray the x-ray and ultrasound are on
the side of the hospital that was hit by
shelling we also need a diesel generator
for the power shortages the ventilators
stop working when the electricity cuts
out
but there's hope and a message to the
world
i hope that we will have a future that
our kids will have a future and a
peaceful sky overhead
this is the most important
for all to be safe and sound
and do you want to say something maya
say
a peaceful sky
assassin al jazeera kharkiv